okay let me take on C1 first because I'm
really attracted to Queen C1 Bishop E5
here if Knight E5 I got Knight G2 a
little bit suspicious maybe but I think
it works Knight G2 I think it should
have worked out for for black and now
with the bishop on C1
um obviously 95 94 could not be as
dangerous as the bishop would not be on
the on the A1 AJ diagonal aiding
impossible night there and this was my
point that I had this little trick as
far as I can see winning an exchange and
most probably the game oh there's Bishop
H6 oh wait a second This is complicated
Knight E1 okay it's not that complicated
so I was thinking of Knight of three
then Bishop three and he's threatening
both E7 and B7 but I go Bishop F3 now
with Bishop is seven there's not a
bishop D1
um remaining a piece up uh and gf3 king
f8 would also have been a PSR